so it's a great joy to be back at Yale I
just taught a class for the first time
in six months which I haven't forgotten
how to do but it is a special pleasure
to be here today and to welcome a friend
and an inspiration Amory Lovins to Yale
and to our community Amerie as many of
you know is the co-founder and currently
chairman and chief scientist of the
Rocky Mountain Institute which is a
leading independent market oriented
I think gamer he likes to call they
think and do tank so not just producing
ideas about how the world might work
better from an energy and environmental
point of view but really trying to step
out and lead the way on some of those
new technologies he's been an
inspiration to me for a very long time
some of you will know that nearly 40
years ago
Amerie launched a concept called the
soft energy path in which he helped
focus the world and really for the first
time in a systematic and thoughtful way
on the opportunity for energy efficiency
as a way of addressing rising energy
demands in a rising set of prices around
energy and I think that focus on the
demand side of the equation prior to
that everyone had thought the answer to
energy problems was more supply was it
breakthrough in thinking and Amery has
over the intervening time been an
adviser to companies and governments
across the world more than 50 different
countries and within our country many
companies and other entities including
the department's of energy and defense
he's won more prizes than I could even
name in an introduction but including
the Blue Planet prize the Volvo Prize
the Onassis Prize the Nissan Prize a
MacArthur and Ashoka fellowships the
Heinz prize the Lindberg prize I won't
go on he really has had an extraordinary
career in breaking new ground in terms
of thinking and he has done so in a way
that brings analytic rigor and fresh
ideas to many topics he's written or
co-authored or co-edited 31 books in
over 400 papers
his latest book well he has two that
have been of recently of interest in
2004 he wrote winning the oil endgame
some of you I know have read that and
more recently and really uh just
released is reinventing fire bold
business solutions for the new energy
era and it's really that topic how we
reimagine our energy future that is here
today to talk about and to address it's
a great pleasure to have him hosted by
the Yale Center for environmental law
and policy as well as the business and
environment Club at the Yale School of
Management and the Center for business
and the environment at Yale
Amory's visit is supported by the
General Electric Foundation and the GE
sustainability leaders program
Emrys going to talk for a minutes and
then take questions if you do want to
ask a question please wave and we will
try to get you a microphone let us know
who you are
and all of you have signed in and if you
haven't we're gonna by implication have
you signed in meaning you have agreed to
be taped because we are videotaping this
and running it live on the Internet so
if anyone does not consent to having
their voice or vision on that internet
please go out and I guess watch from the
outside so thank you all very much again
and it really is a pleasure to be able
to welcome Amory special thanks again to
the GE sustainability leaders program
that helps us bring practitioners and
thought leaders here to Yale and to
really make this institution a forum for
debate over the challenges and
opportunities that we face in
implementing sustainability across
environment energy and economic
dimensions so with that let me say thank
you again Emery and the podium is yours
well thank you Dan for your wonderful
work at Yale and for now the people of
Connecticut after that gracious
introduction I can't wait to hear what
I'm going to say the energy debate that
keeps coming at us in the media and
politics if clearly framed would ask
something like would you rather die of
oil Wars or climate change or nuclear
holocaust or perhaps all of the above
but what if we could choose none of the
above what if we could make energy do
our work without working our undoing
could we have fuel without fear could we
reinvent fire fire you see made us human
fossil fuels made us modern and now we
need a new fire that makes us safe
secure healthy and durable this has now
become possible in fact it works better
and cost less than what we've been doing
so far so let's explore how to make that
change four-fifths of the world's energy
still comes from burning every year
about four cubic miles of fossil fuels
the rotted remains of primeval swamp goo
those fossil fuels have built our
civilization created our wealth enriched
the lives of billions yet their rising
cost to our security economy health and
environment are eroding if not out
weighing their benefits that's why we
need a new fire switching from the old
fire to the new fire means shifting two
big stories oil and electricity each of
which releases now two-fifths of fossil
carbon yet they're distinct our
electricity comes less than one
and from oil but nearly half from cold
three-fourths of our oil fuels
transportation 3/4 of our electricity
powers buildings the rest of both runs
factories so very efficient vehicles
buildings and factories save oil and
coal and also natural gas that can
displace them both but today's energy
system is not just inefficient it's also
disconnected aging dirty and insecure it
needs refurbishment by 2050 it could
become efficient connected and
distributed with elegantly frugal autos
buildings and factories all relying on a
secure modern and resilient electricity
system we can eliminate our addiction to
oil and coal by 2050 and use one-third
less natural gas while switching to
efficient use and renewable supplies by
2050 this could cost five trillion
dollars less in net present value than
business as usual assuming that carbon
emissions and all other externalities
are worth zero a conservatively low
estimate yet this cheaper energy system
could support a hundred fifty eight
percent bigger US economy all without
oil or coal or nuclear energy moreover
this transition needs no new inventions
and no new federal taxes mandate
subsidies or laws and running Washington
gridlock well you say that again I'm
going to tell you how the United States
can get completely off oil five trillion
dollars cheaper with no act of Congress
led by business for profit this energy
solution is going to be designed and
driven from the c-suite not from K
Street it's going to use our most
effective institutions private
enterprise Co evolving with civil
society sped by military innovation to
go around our least effective
institutions
and whether you most care about profits
and jobs and competitive advantage or
national security or environmental
stewardship and climate protection and
Public Health reinventing fire makes
sense and makes money General Eisenhower
reputedly said that expanding the
boundaries of a tough problem makes it
soluble by encompassing
more options and more synergies
reinventing fire therefore integrates
all four energy using sectors
transportation buildings industry and
electricity and it integrates four kinds
of innovation technology design policy
and business strategy those combinations
are a lot more than the sum of their
parts especially in creating deeply
disruptive business opportunities in
truth we would save a lot more than five
trillion dollars for example America
burns oil costing two billion dollars a
day but our analysis which I will
describe left out its hidden costs paid
not at the pump but through our taxes or
incomes those extra costs are at least
four billion dollars a day or one and a
half trillion dollars a year in three
roughly equal parts the first half
trillion dollars a year is sucked out of
our economy mainly by OPEX monopoly
pricing which our oil dependence makes
possible the second half trillion
dollars a year is the market price the
market or the market value of oils price
volatility that whipsaws our whole
economy for 40 years now every recession
has been preceded by an oil price spike
but just the daily yo-yo of prices
imposes cost and risk on every user of
oil the third half trillion dollars a
year we pay to keep military forces
ready for Persian Gulf interventions
that is about 10 times what we pay for
oil from the Persian Gulf and it rivals
our total defence spending at the height
of the coal
war oil is also finite the Pentagon is
preparing to need no oil and the rest of
us should too so we ought to get off oil
just to enhance national security and
save money at the fuel pump even if it's
hidden costs were not twice its pump
price bringing its total economic cost
above a sixth of GDP plus we haven't
counted this yet any damage to health
environments global stability and
development or our nation's independence
and reputation where to start
well our mobility fuel goes three fifths
to automobiles so let's start by making
autos oil free two-thirds of the energy
needed to move a typical car is caused
by its weight and every unit of energy
we save at the wheels by reducing weight
or drag saves seven units of fuel at the
tank for the past quarter century though
epidemic obesity has made our two-ton
steel autos gain weight twice as fast as
we have but today ultra light ultra
strong materials like carbon fiber
composites can make dramatic weight
savings snowball and can make autos
simpler and cheaper to build lighter and
more slippery autos need less force to
move them so their engines get smaller
such vehicle Fitness then makes electric
autos affordable because their batteries
or fuel cells get smaller lighter and
cheaper so their sticker price will fall
to about today's level with far lower
driving costs these innovations can
transform automakers from wringing tiny
savings out of Victorian steel stamping
at engine technologies to the steeply
falling costs of three mutually
reinforcing technologies advanced
lightweight materials manufacturing and
electric propulsion sales can grow and
prices drop faster with a temporary
Phebe 8 that is rebates for efficient
new cars paid for by fees on inefficient
ones in its first two years the biggest
of five European fee bait programs
tripled the speed of improving auto
efficiency the resulting shift to
electric autos will be as game-changing
as shifting from small improvements in
typewriters to the dramatic Moore's law
driven gains in computers computers and
electronics of course are now America's
biggest industry typewriter makers have
vanished
so vehicle fitness opens a new
automotive competitive strategy to
double oil savings in 40 years and that
in turn makes affordable the
electrification that can save the rest
of the oil leaders will be laggards just
like hybrid cars only faster because
hybrids represent only one learning
curve not three synergistic ones America
could be leading this next automotive
revolution currently the leader is
Germany last year Volkswagen announced
2013 production of this 230-mile a
gallon carbon fiber plug-in hybrid and
BMW announced 2013 production of this
carbon fiber electric car they confirmed
that its carbon fiber is paid for by
needing fewer batteries and their CEO
said we do not intend to be a typewriter
maker because he can look across Munich
to where Olympia used to be making
excellent typewriters howdy claims it's
going to beat them both by a year now
even faster and cheaper manufacturing
technologies than those German firms are
currently using made this carbon fiber
carbon cap in one minute seven years ago
and you can tell from the sound how
extremely stiff and strong it is
I'm gonna pass it around don't worry
about dropping it Tom Friedman who acted
as hard as he could with a sledgehammer
without even scuffing it it's tougher
than titanium now these techniques can
scale to automotive speed and cost with
aerospace performance and when we do
that with all our auto making it'll save
four-fifths of the capital needed for
auto making and it will save oil
equivalent to discovering one and a half
Saudi Arabia's or half an OPEC by
drilling in the Detroit formation a very
perspective play those mega barrels
under Detroit cost about 18 bucks a
barrel they are all American carbon free
and inexhaustible the same physics in
the same business logic also apply to
big vehicles in the five years through
2010 Walmart has saved 60% of the fuel
per ton-mile and it's big fleet of heavy
trucks through smarter designs and
logistics just the technological fuel
saving in heavy trucks can rise to
two-thirds and when combined with
tripled to quintupled efficiency
aircraft we can end up saving about
point nine trillion dollars net present
value and today's military revolution in
energy efficiency will speed all of
these civilian advances much as military
Rd in the past created the internet GPS
the jet engine and microchip industries
now as we design and build vehicles
better we can also use them smarter this
is a graph of traffic congestion with
the morning and evening rush hours and
if if that were an electricity load
shaped how much IT enabled demand
response and pricing and Smart Grid
would we throw at it to flatten it out
but by not yet doing that for road
traffic we are wasting many billions of
dollars a year in idle people idle
vehicles and I don't roads but now for
powerful techniques can cut needless
driving we can charge real time driving
costs per mile not
per gallon use smart IT to enhance
transit and empower car sharing and
ride-sharing allow lucrative Smart
Growth real estate models so while more
people are already where they want to be
and don't need to go somewhere else and
use IT to make traffic free-flowing
together those four proven methods can
give us the same or better access with
46 to 84 percent less
driving saving another point four
trillion dollars plus another point
three trillion dollars from smarter use
of trucks you know you start adding
these things up pretty soon you're
talking real money so forty years hence
a for more mobile US economy can use no
oil saving or displacing each barrel for
just twenty five dollars rather than
buying it for upwards of a hundred saves
four trillion dollars in present value
counting all its hidden costs at zero so
to get mobility without oil we can first
get efficient then switch fuels those
125 to 240 miles a gallon equivalent
autos can use any mixture now unknowable
because we don't know how the
competition will play out of electricity
hydrogen fuel cells and advanced
biofuels anyone will do we have three
trucks and airplanes can realistically
use advanced biofuels or hydrogen where
trucks could even burn natural gas but
no vehicles will need oil any biofuels
the US might need just 0.3 million
barrels a day made 2/3 from waste could
be produced without displacing cropland
or harming climate or soil our team
speeds up these kinds of oil savings by
institutional acupuncture and is where
the business logic is congested not
flowing properly we stick little needles
in it to get it flowing with partners
ranging from Ford to Walmart to the
Pentagon I think most of the six sectors
we need to transform are already at or
past their tipping point in fact three
years ago mainstream analysts started to
see peak oil
not in supply but in demand and deutsche
bank even forecast that world oil use
will peak around 2016 in short oil is
becoming uncompetitive even at low
prices before it becomes unavailable
even at high prices but electrified
autos don't need to add new burdens to
the electricity system rather when smart
autos exchange electrons and information
through smart buildings with smart grids
they add flexibility and storage to the
grid
that help integrate variable solar and
wind power so electrified autos make the
auto and electricity problems easier to
solve together than separately and they
converge the oil story with our second
big story saving electricity and then
making it differently those twin
revolutions in electricity promise more
numerous diverse and profound
disruptions than in any other sector as
21st century technology and speed
collide head-on with 20th and 19th
century institutions rules and cultures
changing how we make electricity though
gets easier if we need less of it today
it's mostly wasted and efficiency
technologies keep improving faster than
we apply them so the potential savings
keep getting even bigger and cheaper but
as efficiency gains in buildings and
industry start to add pace economic
growth America's electricity use could
start shrinking
despite the electrified autos which
really don't add that much because
they're very efficient we can do this by
reasonably accelerating existing trends
over the next 40 years
buildings can triple or quadruple their
energy productivity saving 1.4 trillion
net dollars with a 33 percent internal
rate of return the savings are worth
four times their cost and industry can
accelerate to doubling its energy
productivity for the 21 percent internal
rate of return but there's even more to
of innovation we call integrative design
that can boost these savings further and
often make very big energy savings cost
less than small or no savings turning
diminishing returns into expanding
returns that's how our 2010 retrofit is
saving over two-fifths of the Empire
State building's energy remanufacturing
it's six and a half thousand windows
on-site into super windows that pass
light but block heat plus better lights
and office equipment reduce the maximum
cooling load by a third and then
renovating smaller chillers instead of
installing bigger ones saved seventeen
million dollars a capital cost that
helped pay for the other improvements
and cut the payback to three years my
own house high in the rocky mountains at
seventy one hundred feet where it used
to go down to minus forty seven F minus
forty four C and you can get thirty
three days of continuous midwinter cloud
is another interesting example of
integrative design it helped inspire
32,000 European buildings that need no
heating but have roughly normal
construction cost they don't have to
look like this to work like this they
can look like whatever you want inside
we have grown thirty-nine banana crops
this was just photographed last week you
can see crop number 37 here 38 and 39
are elsewhere and that's with no furnace
there's no heating system this house in
1984 was saving 99 percent of its space
and water heating energy ninety percent
of its electricity all with about of ten
month payback today's technologies which
we've just retrofitted or even better
how much better well we're figuring out
by commissioning some software that's
measuring 300 data points every 20
seconds the trouble is the monitoring
equipped
seems to be using more energy than the
lights and appliances were measuring but
this design approach works well in any
climate including eliminating air
conditioning up to at least 115
Fahrenheit or 46 Celsius with lower
construction cost and better comfort or
a house model on mine was built in
Bangkok and produced superior comfort at
normal construction cost with 90% less
air-conditioning energy I think probably
about everybody in the world lives
somewhere between the climate of Bangkok
and old Snowmass now the key is
integrative design that gives multiple
benefits from single expenditures for
example this arch in the top has 12
functions but only one cost integrative
design can also increase the half
trillion dollars of conventional energy
savings in industry for example three
fifths of the world's electricity runs
motors half of that runs pumps and fans
and those devices can all be improved
but the motor systems that drive them
can also save about half their energy
with a one-year payback by integrating
35 improvements first though we ought to
capture the bigger cheaper savings that
are normally ignored for example pumps
the biggest use of motors move liquid
through pipes a typical industrial
pumping loop was redesigned to use at
least 86 percent less pumping energy not
by getting better pumps but just by
replacing long thin crooked pipes with
fat short straight pipes this also
shrinks the pumping equipment at its
capital cost now this isn't new
technologies about rearranging our metal
furniture so what are such savings mean
for the electricity that's 3/5 used in
motors well from the coal burned in the
power plant to the flow out the pipe
there are so many compounding losses
that only a tenth of the energy actually
gets through as delivered flow but now
that turn those compounding losses
around backwards into compounding
savings and every unit of
flow or friction we save in the pipe
saves 10 units of fuel costs pollution
and global weirding back at the power
plant and also as you go back upstream
the components get smaller and cheaper
our team has lately found such
snowballing energy savings in more than
30 billion dollars worth of industrial
redesigns from data centers and ship
fabs to mines and refineries typically
our retrofit designs save about thirty
to sixty percent of the energy with a
two or three year payback our new
facility designs save more like 40 to 90
odd percent with a lower capital cost
now needing less electricity would of
course ease and speed the shift to new
sources of electricity chiefly
renewables China leads their explosive
growth and their plummeting costs in
fact the photovoltaic module cost shown
here have just fallen off the bottom of
the chart solar and wind power our
marketplace winners today Europe has now
over a million new renewable energy jobs
the big winner Germany has more solar
workers that America has steel workers
already in about 20 states private
installers will be happy to put those
competitive solar cells on your home's
roof with no money down and beat your
utility bill those kinds of unregulated
products could ultimately build into a
virtual utility that bypasses power
companies much as cell phones bypassed
wireline phone companies that sort of
thing gives utility executives the
heebie-jeebies and venture capitalists
sweet dreams half the world's new
generating capacity since 2008 has been
renewable the majority lately in
developing countries in 2010 renewables
except big hydro got a hundred to fifty
1 billion dollars of private investment
and for the first time they surpassed
the total global installed capacity of
nuclear power by adding sixty billion
watts
in a year that happens to be the same
capacity as the solar cells that the
world can now make every year last year
68 percent of Europe's new capacity was
solar or wind in fact solar was the
number one capacity dish and quarter of
the total gas was next wind who was just
edged into third place
in contrast global orders for : nuclear
plants are fading because they cost too
much they have too much financial risk
to attract investors indeed in the
United States no none of the 34 proposed
new nuclear plants has been able to
raise any private capital despite 7
years of being offered hundred plus
percent subsidies so how else could we
replace our coal-fired power plants that
produce about 45 percent of our
electricity
well efficiency and gas can displace all
those coal plants at below just their
operating cost and combined with
renewables can displace all the coal
plants over 23 times at less than their
replacement cost but once is enough and
actually in the past five years 2005
through 10 we don't have the 2011 data
firm yet but in those five years coal
lost already a quarter of its share of
the u.s. electricity market to cheaper
gas efficiency and renewables and that
transition is now well underway we're
often told though that only : nuclear
plants can keep the lights on because
they're 24/7 while wind power and
photovoltaics are variable in hence
unreliable but you know actually no
generator is 24/7 they all break and
when a giant coal or nuclear plant fails
you just lost a billion watts in
milliseconds often before weeks or
months and without warning grids though
routinely handle that kind of
intermittence by backing up failed
plants with working plants and grids can
handle the four castable variations of
solar and wind power in exactly the same
way our hourly simulations show
how largely or wholly renewable grids
can deliver highly reliable power when
forecasted integrated and diversified by
type and location this is true both for
continental areas like the US or Europe
and for smaller areas embedded within
them
for example the isolated Texas grid
summer electric loads can get a lot
smaller and cheaper with efficiency or
smaller and less peaky I should say with
efficiency and then we can install wind
power and solar power these are actual
data so you can see how variable they
are but even at times when they produce
in total too much or too little
electricity they can still be matched to
the load via ice storage air
conditioning smart charging and
discharging of electrified autos and
unobtrusively flexible demand even
within this case at least 86% solar and
wind variable renewables the other 14%
or less can come from dispatchable
renewables like geothermal small hydro
solar thermal electric or feedlot biogas
burned in existing gas turbines so we
can make all the moving parts fit
together by arranging this choreography
properly and some utilities are already
integrating variable renewables in
exactly this way for German States in
2010 were 43 to 52 percent wind powered
Portugal was 45 percent renewable power
Denmark 36 so and now European
experience is supporting a transition
over decades to largely or wholly
renewable electricity for the entire
European Union variable and flexible
resources then can reliably serve steady
loads not in the traditional way giant
fossil fuel to nuclear plants but with
newer resources that meet even better
the classical definition of so-called
base load plants that is they're the
ones with the lowest operating cost so
you dispatch them
they're available America's aging dirty
insecure electricity system has to be
replaced by 2050 and whatever we replace
it with is going to cost about six
trillion dollars a net present value
whether we buy more of what we've got
now or new nuclear build and so-called
clean coal or centralized renewables or
distributed renewables but these four
futures
even though they cost about the same
differ profoundly in their risks around
national security fuel water finance
technology climate and health for
example are over centralized grid is
vulnerable to cascading and potentially
nation shattering blackouts not just the
sort of thing you saw in Connecticut but
on a very much larger scale in duration
caused by solar storms by other natural
disasters by terrorist attacks physical
or cyber but that risk disappears and
all the other risks are best managed
with distributed renewables reorganized
into local micro grids that normally
interconnect but can stand alone at need
this would cost about the same as
business as usual but would maximize
national security customer choice
entrepreneurial opportunity and
innovation together efficient use and
diverse dispersed renewable supply are
starting to flip the whole electricity
sector on its head traditionally of
course utilities build giant : nuclear
plants than big gas plants then maybe a
little efficiency or renewables and
those utilities were rewarded as they
still are in 36 states we're selling you
more electricity but now especially
where regulators are instead reward
cutting your bills the market is
shifting massively towards efficiency
renewables cogeneration and ways to
blend them all together reliably using
less transmission and little or no bulk
electricity storage so our energy future
is not fate but choice and that choice
is very flexible in 1976 for example
government and industry all insisted
that the energy needed to make a dollar
of GDP could never go down I her
ethically suggested it could drop
several fold that's what happened by
twofold so far and yet today's far more
powerful technologies integrative design
and maturing delivery channels can save
even more even faster and cheaper so to
solve the energy problem we just needed
to enlarge it the results may at first
seem incredible but as Marshall McLuhan
said only puny secrets need protection
big discoveries are protected by public
incredulity these Best Buy's also happen
to be the most effective solutions to
some bigger problems climate change
nuclear proliferation energy and
security and energy poverty so now
combine the electricity and oil
revolutions and the strong and
efficiency underlying them and you have
the really big story reinventing fire
we're business enabled and sped by smart
policies in mindful markets can lead the
United States completely off oil and
coal these wedges down here by 2050
saving 5 trillion dollars growing the
economy 2.6 fold strengthening our
national security and by eliminating the
oil and coal reducing fossil carbon
emissions by 82 to 86 percent now if you
like any of those outcomes any you can
support reinventing fire without needing
to agree about which outcome is more
important that is focusing on outcomes
not motives can turn gridlock and
conflict into a unifying solution
to America's energy challenge our team
that helps smart companies to get
unstuck and to speed this journey of
course there are still a lot of old
thinking around - as a woman very strong
once said not all the fossils are in the
fuel but as DuPont former chairman Edgar
Willard reminded us firms hampered by
old thinking won't be a problem because
they simply won't be around long term
what I've described is not just a once
in a civilization business opportunity
it's one of the greatest transformations
in the history of our species we humans
are inventing a new fire not dug from
below but flowing from above not scarce
but bountiful not local but everywhere
not transient but permanent not costly
but free and not for a little biofuel
grown in ways that sustain and endure
this new fire is flameless efficiently
used it really can make energy do our
work without working our undoing each of
you owns a piece of that five trillion
dollar prize and our book reinventing
fire details how each of you can capture
that opportunity so with the
conversation just begun at reinventing
fire calm let me now invite you to
engage with us at Rocky Mountain
Institute and with each other to help
make the world richer fairer cooler and
safer by reinventing fire thank you
so I think a Murray's prepared to take
some questions please raise your hand
we've got mics here to run to you let us
know who you are
and sharp-pointed focus questions please
sir hi Chris help and Celtic energy
thank you for everything you do what an
inspiration okay what do you think we
need to do in our federal level to make
this happen because it's it's a huge
issue and there's a lot of disbelievers
and naysayers ignorant as they may be in
certain respects what can we do now
notice I didn't say no policy innovation
was required we do actually need some to
either unlock or enable or to speed the
transition I described we just didn't
find any that required an act of
Congress they can be done federally
added an administrative level or they
can be done at a state level which is
where we regulate almost all our utility
activity anyway so everything I
described could be done federally or by
the states where they have the
jurisdiction like utility Commission's
you could do for example auto fee Bates
federally or you could do them at a
state or regional level for example this
is one of the states one of the 16 that
cooperates with California under the
Clean Air Act California is seriously
considering fee Bates they actually
passed them by a 7 to 1 margin 30 odd
years ago and got pocket vetoed because
people hadn't quite done their homework
with the automaker's first but now that
we have worked with the automakers on
how to design fee Bates properly and now
that California still has over 3 to 1
support for the concept that could well
happen and Connecticut could actually
lead that and by the way if we had fee
Bates in California plus 16 that's two
fifths of the national auto market
that's enough to swing the whole thing
decoupling in shared savings that is
rewarding utilities for cutting your
bill not selling more energy is really a
state prerogative however we do need
federal action preferably and the
Federal Energy Regulatory Commission has
been moving very consistently in this
direction to get pricing transparency to
have to form bigger and faster markets
that that clear maybe every five or ten
minutes instead of hourly or daily and
to make sure that there is full and fair
competition for example there's only 13
states now in which efficiency and
demand response are allowed to compete
against the supply side this is stupid
everything ought to compete so we can
choose the best buys there is
fortunately a lot of wonderful military
leadership on both resilient electric
supplies and efficiency and that is a
federal activity and I think you'll find
such a strong consensus around it that
it isn't much interfered with by present
politics because it's it's really about
operational readiness and effectiveness
and saving money and lives we've had
over a thousand service members now
killed in convoy attacks mostly hauling
fuel that's mostly wasted and the
combatant commanders take that very
seriously but I don't think it's
necessary to have federal consensus the
few things that need to be done by
federal regulation are all
administrative we have found only one
trivial exception you would forego I
think it's point three million barrels a
day of heavy truck savings by 2050 if
you were not able to get an act of
Congress author or harmonizing highway
heavy truck rules on size and weight
between federal and state highways but
that's only a tenth of the maximum
biofuels you might need anyway so it's
not really important whether we do that
or not it would just be
good for trucking industry for reducing
road wear and improving safety so I
think Washington will do whatever it
does and there's no need to wait again
let this be enabled by policy at an
appropriate and accountable level but
led by business for profit that's the
most dynamic force in our society that's
where big change can go to scale yes hi
my name is Lisa I was wondering how you
arrived at the deadline of 2050 it's a
nice round number but why not you know
30 40 60 and how realistic is that
considering past progress you know maybe
you could explain 2050 turned out to be
about how long it would take to complete
this change if the rates of adoption
already achieved in the leading states
were achieved nationwide over the next
20 odd to 30 years which we thought was
a reasonable ramp up rate and we have
taken full account of the lags for
retooling retraining and so on I think
we could do it a bit faster than that
but it is a round number actually the
federal forecast which were our base
case and in 2035 so we had to
extrapolate those to get a base case to
2050 to compare with and get our prices
from but since it's just to turn the
crank model anyway that's a pretty
accurate method but there's nothing
magic about the number and of course we
need to get started now I think we
already have whether we realize it or
not someone once asked Dana Meadows do
we have enough time to get out of this
mess and she correct the answer we have
exactly enough time starting now whereas
bill McDonough says negligence begins
tomorrow
Cynthia Parker regarding buildings what
can you say about geothermal interior
climate control in terms of helping
toward your goal well in good sites with
good technique and you have to do it
right and watch out for corrosion and
sediment and all that other stuff
geothermal heat pumps are a legitimate
technique in general it may be an even
better deal to super insulate the
buildings so they don't need heating or
cooling and this is now a pretty common
practice in Europe I mentioned the
32,000 passive buildings there that
don't need heat and have about normal
construction cost but there are also
many passive buildings now that are
retrofitted hundred-year-old Viennese
apartment houses half-timbered
Elizabethan houses you know a lot of
historic buildings are super insulated
or if they're not listed if they're
these drab stucco things you can super
outs elate them and build a tea cosy
around them and that is being done
cost-effectively in climates similar to
or worse than yours southern Sweden for
example so I think this is a the next
revolution in in building technique and
it takes a lot of skill especially in
air tightening but those skills have
been rapidly built up in Europe led by
Germany and you know when we led the
greening of the White House that was
about as historic a building as we have
and the some of the windows were so old
they were not just rolled glass instead
of float glass they were blown glass but
those made the outer lights of the new
super windows plus some other things the
Secret Service wanted and so on and
those super windows work just fine you
can't tell the difference from the
outside so I think this is a lot of good
skilled work to be done over decades and
I would generally prioritize it over the
mechanical solutions it's usually
cheaper even in retrofit to try to get
rid of mechanicals rather than make them
more complicated so geothermal works
that you'd have to analyze whether it's
the best buy Jake Jake Seligmann FES I
was just curious about the your
electricity projections and the you know
you said we need to in order to make
that dispatch dispatch mount model work
it needs to be orchestrated
intelligently and I'm just curious about
what specifically can you envision
happening at maybe the ISO level or even
at the utility level to actually make
that happen
well there's nothing magic about this
when the when the West Danish grid first
tried this contemplated the idea
actually it took them about seven years
to get comfortable with it they they
thought originally you could only do
maybe three to five percent variable
renewables without lights going off and
then 10 15 20 and 25 you know now in a
normal wind year Denmark well as of 2010
it had the capacity to be 36 percent
renewable 26 of which is wind and they
don't see a limit and Denmark has under
its conservative government a national
policy of getting completely off fossil
fuel in all primary energy by 2050 to
improve their economy and security
they've figured out how to make it
almost entirely self-financing it's
quite a good deal it's already helping
their economy not only in in having
powerful export industries but in
reducing their exposure to volatile fuel
prices the so the changes are actually
some technological but much more
cultural and institutional and we're
actually embarking on some exercises
within the electricity industry to speed
up that learning we had for example
an interesting case a couple of years
ago we were working with a very large
and renowned utility that's mainly
nuclear and coal and they thought you
could only do 2 or 3% variable
renewables without the lights going out
and we surmise that this might perhaps
be an organizational learning problem
yes indeed it turns out they did their
dispatch models on stuff that runs on a
mainframe overnight and gives you reams
of numbers you can't understand so we
introduced them to our Mac model that
produced this it runs in 15 seconds and
produces color graphics so you can
actually see how the moving parts fit
together and after a few weeks of guided
play with this the utilities head of
strategy formerly head of operations
respected nuclear engineer stood up in
front of the executive group and said
you know you're not gonna believe this
but this is what we found I'm perfectly
comfortable now we can do 30 to 50
percent variable renewables that's not
an upper valve that's just as far as we
analyzed it just means operating our
existing assets in a different way that
is much closer to classical economic
dispatch it respects all of our ramp
rates and maintenance schedules and so
on we will have better reliability out
of it and we may well make more money on
it that's the kind of shift in thinking
that happens when you have the right
tools to understand how this new
choreography can work and of course we
have to do a lot of fixing up of the
grid because we have obsolete
you know distribution controls we have
to make it secure we have to ought to
make it we have to make it
bi-directional that stuff's happening
anyway real-time pricing is really
helpful bigger and faster clearing
markets would be essential but this is
not difficult it's just different and
it's a lot easier than not doing it and
continuing to cope with the cascading
blackout and other kinds of really scary
problems that we have right
now that we have to grow our way out of
sir thanks Amy I had the pleasure of
also hearing you at Greenbuild and then
read your most of your book I was just
curious agriculture which is a huge user
of fossil fuel how do you where do you
put them in the mix we actually did
quite a lot of research on that which my
colleagues persuaded me to largely take
out of the book it was about one thing
too many but that's a much longer
conversation at a very important one
partly because quite a lot of
agricultural trace gas is important to
climate partly because we're ruining a
lot of our swamp fertility or losing a
lot of our soil partly because of water
partly because of food of the narrowness
of the crop base genetics and so on my
generally I think where the analysis
points is the natural systems
agriculture that looks and acts more
like ecosystems is much more likely to
succeed ecologically and economically
than a very input intensive and
essentially fragile or unreserve
climate changes the more that becomes
the case also there are some important
structural changes we need to make for
other reasons for example there's now an
important Public Health coalition
emerging to ban the prophylactic use of
feedlot antibiotics and that would I
think put conventional feedlots and
other intensive rearing methods out of
business and require more humane and
ecologically sensible methods which do
not actually have to cost more I live
for example in western Colorado whose
traditional ranching economy was organic
cow calf operations as they ate grass
that's what they're designed for and the
only reason that that isn't flourishing
now especially with all the concerns
about prions and stuff
is that USDA has refused to put
inspectors on the western slope that
would make it legal to run an abattoir
there and by the time you shipped your
critter over the continental dividing
back it cost too much but that's not a
necessary problem that's a fairly simple
regulatory obstacle and I think probably
reform of the beef system is the biggest
lever in the world for improving the
healthfulness of our food and the
economy of a lot of our rural areas it's
a longer story than that but perhaps
that's a start sir J Bruns the Hartford
in Hartford Connecticut it sounds to me
that the description that you make is
that we're probably already on this
glide path to get to the desired state
in 2050 because once and all the pieces
are already there private sector just
has to take into account those economic
indicators and and do what it does I
guess my question is what do you see as
potential things that would intervene to
inhibit that and to to block getting to
that end state in 2050 well I suppose if
we have an attack of the stupids we
could keep increasing runaway subsidies
we're in a subsidy arms race on stuff
that cannot compete in the market I
think given the fiscal climate that's
not very likely that we are more likely
to come to our senses and start running
the subsidy arms rates backwards towards
zero and instead of adding subsidies
take them away in a reasonably balanced
fashion I could actually enjoy a
televised hearing in which a number of
sworn energy executives are in front of
a legislative committee that pulls out a
new unbiased GAO CBO
we need advise by say jug cop low at
EarthLink dotnet who really understand
subsidies and they'd say mmm mr. jones
it looks like your industry got eleven
billion dollars from this subsidy last
year and mr. Smith you seem to have
gotten about eight billion from oh but
senator those aren't subsidies oh so you
wouldn't mind if we took him away would
you that's how you tell if their
subsidies and I think people who really
do care about competition in free
markets could have a lot of fun smoking
out the corporate socialists and free
marketeers clothing
I think whatever political belief system
you have that would be a good thing
and if we want to get our taxes down
that's a pretty good start there are you
know there are likely to be some bad
things happening in the world which
could cause us to respond stupidly again
the more people understand what's
actually happening in the energy
transition I've described the less
likely we are to go off on bizarre
adventures pursuing somebody's favorite
technology that they say is essential
and I I wrote a piece some years ago
called drilling in all the wrong places
which is on our my dot org describing in
two very terse pages maybe it's just one
why conservatives should be particularly
offended by this nutty idea of drilling
in the Arctic National Wildlife Refuge
because the oil there is insecure
uncompetitive on economic and
unnecessary and for a conservative those
are particularly dirty words rightly so
that though that thesis is not yet
widely known but you might ask yourself
why are none of the oil majors in the
least interested in oil from that source
because it's grotesquely uh neck anomic
and risky and it's about the last thing
they'd ever be interested in they've
made that very clear way in the back
quickly could you just comment on global
hydrofracking technology and how that
will impact on the marketplace and maybe
the hidden costs involved yeah well a
lot of parts of the world do have tight
and shale gas that could be fracked
although not perhaps as easily as some
here the fracking generically of course
is not a new technique the way it's
being applied mixed with horizontal
drilling in those shales has many
fundamental uncertainties some of them
are about the long-term produce ability
profile some about the underlying gassy
economics if you take away the oil light
sweet crude oil by-product that's
driving a lot of the early plays and
they use it or lose it leases that are
driving rather frenetic drilling of the
lake some are around induced seismicity
earthquake issues some are around water
use water contamination local site
impacts there there's a lot of stuff
that we need to sort out it'll take
probably a decade to resolve those
uncertainties if they resolved favorably
we'll be glad we have that additional
resource if we don't we won't be too
disappointed because we won't need most
of that gas anyway the main effect
internationally will be to decouple
guests from oil prices quite a lot of
the gas price maybe a third of it and
the world has already we're still
contractually tied to oil price which is
nutty and that that's going to strain
and break and I think it's probably not
very good news for gas problem which
might change Russian behavior about gas
as a political tool so yeah that's good
we're in for interesting times and of
course the gas markets already roiled by
events in Japan but I think the it's an
interesting example of many of how the
hydrocarbon industries have
extraordinary skills and their assets
and capabilities will be very useful in
the new world in a number of perhaps
unexpected ways and the hydrocarbon they
have in the ground will hydrogen in it
we'll be worth more without the carbon
than with the carbon even without carbon
pricing they'll make more money taking
hydrogen out in reformers than putting
more in in refineries there will be a
number of interesting surprises but
those industries could have a bright
future gas could be a useful
transitional fuel and ultimately in a
few decades after 2050 I expect we'll
get largely off gas as a fuel and it
will remain a very useful feedstock our
analysis was only about fuels not
feedstocks you know not not the
molecular use only the combustion use
and fossil fuels are really good
feedstocks and they'll have to compete
with the bio feedstocks Amery thank you
very much I think we should continue the
conversation outside the door in a more
informal way but there's really a great
pleasure to have you here thank you
thank you